hey guys I'm Ryan right Alyssa be crazy
and I'm Murray we're gonna watch the
Assassin's Creed trailer today
Assassin's Creed rogue came out last
week cinematic trailer I II just keep
seeing these trailers and for a while
you run out of opinions because all they
keep doing is going yeah it's gonna be a
good game it's gonna it's gonna rock
it's gonna rock no I don't feel like
they're really committed to making a
trailer awesome they're gonna throw a
curveball just you know bolts and curve
look around kitchen faces that's fine my
balls curved - interesting mmm it's a
way that's weird didn't know sometimes
penis is curved but my balls actually
four penises Street so apparently penis
is curving is like a sign of diabetes
what I think it's diabetes yeah so uh
any of you subscribers out there if you
know this bird see a doctor on that nose
Oh
let's check this [ __ ] out
I hope that's a playable costumes that
forced you to question your own moral
code my choice has led me here standing
against those I once called brothers
is to relay brown meat rate rather
or renegade
so much like this guy it's ridiculous
matters is that I followed my own greed
Assassin's Creed rogue
pre-order now you see the Siege afford
to sell permission Wow um I'm so
intrigued right now I am how I have been
in that situation one too many times and
yeah I always shoot the person it's
never a conflicting issue never
conflicting sometimes sometimes their
little woman so is he that's where Sally
its he an assassin going after other
assassins that I saw the maple leaves
falling in the the beginning and I felt
like perhaps he was done Canadian going
up to the French crown which I don't
think it's at all what's actually
happening but it's fun de belief
subtlety I really honestly I hope they
go after other assassins I feel like
that'd be a really cool game changer you
know Marie I've noticed something um you
don't look at the camera that often you
know no no but I'm talking to you guys I
know he ever deep are you scared to look
at the camera
um the camera does not have a soul and
I'm pretty sure that no the soul is in
the audience right this is what other he
likes guys is what I just understand
this like a lot of folklore um in a lot
of cultures that cameras steal your soul
so the camera doesn't have a full and
it's trying to take my soul I'm Freddy
that's a terrifying pot what's happening
is is that I am trying to hang on to my
humanity uh you guys have given it up
but I am terrified of this this camera
yeah well you know by looking at the
camera it creates a connection with the
audience it's like I'm in the room with
you right now
huh it's called breaking the fourth wall
people breaking the fourth wall
sometimes you just got to do it you know
I don't like I don't like secrets out
there I'm telling you guys what works
about this show right now you do break
the fourth wall uh constantly constantly
you also constantly acknowledge the fact
that you're breaking the fourth wall
I do do this often I do the attention to
detail in these graphics are always
[ __ ] amazing you know what really
impressed me this time what the grass I
was looking at that video I was looking
at the grass going that looks like real
grass right now like I've seen grass
like that before
and that is what that grass looks that's
the kind of grass that you sit there and
pick because the middle part comes right
out of me yeah exactly that's perfect
it's a perfect yeah I know what you're
talking about yeah they really got the
grass I'm in this game and this
character that they have he's a total
badass you know it's like anytime they
have a bet you know like I wanna
learning games where the main characters
kind of a [ __ ] yes kind of not that I
can name off the bat I feel like there's
a lot of internet games where you're
like like flash games okay whenever
there's a badass dude it's like it
automatically makes me want to be him
for a day it's like when you play as
Master Chief when you play assault snake
when you play as you go around like
women charted leaning against walls
quick huh yeah it's really [ __ ] fun
and uh this this franchise is brilliant
it's a brilliant franchise really liked
it a lot first one's kind of complicated
no is the second one the first day the
second ones are just complicated surely
because they hadn't really figured out
exactly what the triggers and buttons
were they just made the controls
confusing third one technically was
Brotherhood in the series right no it
wasn't an assassin's creed 3 & 4 and
then they got that was after it was
brotherhood revelation then 3 by the
third one anyway by the third one in the
series they picked it up and they got it
together and they made it consistent the
first one the second one they didn't
know what they were doing it was a
disaster good night guys
but the controls are just amusing you
know what bothers me hair I just want to
point out that his hair was like
sticking straight
that's his neck everything else was like
flowing really well and it looks like he
had gelled his power he drives me nuts
when my info make like 90% of their
graphics beautiful and then just take
one thing and like like cuz he probably
never pulls his hood down so they're
just like yeah [ __ ] it I'll just have
this weird yeah [ __ ] me floating
ponytail get this [ __ ] thanks for
telling me that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects there's
cool [ __ ] on there really cool stuff you
know we do gameplays we do cooking make
up a lot of great stuff on our channel
if you're really into that kind of make
up yeah will you make a we do make up
vlogs you know like what the best kind
of makeup is out there dancing tutorials
and dance
tutorials exercise tutorials twos will
be offered there's animation all of you
have really expanded the channel in my
tunic absence it's there's no longer
trailer reactions like this is just it's
all gonna be silly animation normal yeah
this is uncomfortable right now to do
this no more movie reviews no short
films just and strictly other crap and
it's a variety channel but no more movie
stuff we make viral videos you wish you
could make a viral figure yeah [ __ ] come
on guys we need a viral video please
share this on your Facebook share it
share we really want a viral video what
would I say just more sharing is caring
ha she's the first one to ever say that
I've never heard that phrase really
really fascinating I've heard up at now
on YouTube I'm gonna shout some rogues
out yeah what part of the day now every
once in a while you know like some
people don't ask for a shout out but I
really want to give them a shout out
because I think they deserve one and
you're probably gonna guess why this
person's getting a shout out London City
girl TV she is uh from London I believe
and she's she has her own movie review
show it's actually a pretty good show
and I quite enjoy listening to her
reviews and watching her reviews
specifically watching her reviews I like
watching you I think about you sometimes
aren't you a charmer I feel like she
needs to be afraid a little bit that you
said that why she's no I think she's
beautiful and she's fairly intellectual
and I could see us very compatible
sexually to I could tell what kind of
girl she is mm-hmm
those London chicks are [ __ ] crazy
crazy in the sack read that on an urban
dictionary cuz you always Chester with
dictionary yeah really good has facts
Andy the vlogger um he wants a shout out
and he said he'll [ __ ] bricks if he gets
one I've been really painful don't do
that don't do that man no last time I
should have brick had it on you know
anal bleeding for several weeks how to
take him into the hospital that was not
fun that was not fun but trust me I was
able to fit that break down my throat
gay guys and talking
I can do things for you even if you're
not getting used Wong experiment trust
me this mouth can fit several in there
actually
um on a serious note Alyssa's mom can
expand her mouth the most out of any ha
c'mon Alyssa's wife see her mom open her
mouth and it is kind of ridiculous why
don't you make my voice sound weird well
I'm just saying that you know if you're
watching I'm just saying that if you
wanted to pleasure several people at the
same time you'd be very capable of doing
that mrs. Alyssa ah I really like your
mom Gavin Flynn shout-out please um okay
I want to acknowledge this
I've tried fixing this I've consulted a
lot of people to on one of our
Assassin's Creed videos the Arnold
Master one that that one for some reason
won't play on like people's phones or
iPods and I really don't know why it was
the second time I've uploaded it still
can't figure out what's going on with it
but um I you know honestly I'm saying I
hate to say this because you know
they're there my god but I think YouTube
might have had a little malfunction yeah
yeah so uh consult youtube calling
youtube it's so easy to get through to
people on youtube if you need to speak
to a customer service representative you
call within a second here we're there
it's amazing the level of communication
I don't even think they have a phone I
don't even have a phone anyone ever
communicates by phone and all their
emails say do not reply you make it
impossible but um yeah Gavin couldn't
watch it on his iPod so I wanted to
apologize to Gavin Flynn for that so
your shoutout is unique because it's
actually an apology shoutout my friend
I'm sorry that's something you just
don't hear from this guy oh yeah I
rarely apologize relish in it
yeah we've pickles ketchup yeah how many
times we talked about her mom you think
once that I say I'm sorry I really not
some on camera that bit early off
damn I've never actually apologized and
I'm not going to that's my point
stand by what I said mom I am so sorry
Gavin you must stand by what you believe
and if you believe a mom is sexy stand
by it stand by it
you know I saw teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles recently apparently a lot of
subscribers really liked that movie I
thought it was fun and enjoyable and I
even said you'll have a good time
watching it but I didn't necessarily
recommend it but I'd say that you go
check it out for yourself because you
might honestly like it and it's okay if
you like it but I got a lot of people
mad at me a lot of people mad at me but
you got to stick by your guns my friend
you know taught me that Bill Murray
good one you know Bill Murray is right
yeah he's the comedian I know who Bill
Murray is okay movies ghostbusters you
seen guys these Ghostbusters okay broken
flowers beautiful stripes you should try
everything straight how did Grandpa okay
seem I know bill might have just seen
Caddyshack you know what how do you
track is the only one of all those ones
that I actually have seen not worth it
no one likes it not worth a single
minute yeah
it's not on Netflix Instant No that's
been the try to watch it I no one would
watch it is horrible but the sequel is
great I wanted to rewatch ground on
States no the Netflix Instant either
Netflix doesn't seem to want me to watch
Bill Murray film I don't think Bill
Murray wants you to watch his films
anyway guys this has been the longest
video of my life that's suck